I am very
excited as is especially my friend yeah
yeah for the upcoming
this is actually this is him excited let
me tell you how much I can't wait for
this uh
the uh I I in this era now where people
were saying I don't even I don't know if
I want to go to the theater anymore the
idea of going and seeing a new Indiana
Jones movie is absolutely thrilling to
me and I I'm gonna go to the theaters uh
to see it if they're gonna see it at all
I hope they'll see it I will make them
personally yeah but I can't imagine I I
think it there's I think all of them
have been spectacular your family are
not an audience you know no exactly yeah
home yeah it's not it's not fair to the
movie right I mean yeah you can see it
at home if you wanted to maybe later
right
but give it a chance go to a movie
theater yeah be in the dark with strange
people
I've done that and I've done that and
I've gone to a movie
one was slightly more erotic than the
other
I'll say
but uh I can't imagine seeing uh you
know an Indiana Jones film any other way
I just can't I think it would be uh I I
would and and the thing is I know it's
going to be an event because I know that
my son who's 17 loves the franchise he's
going to want to go I mean this is going
to be a thing where we can all go as a
family if they allow me I get to go too
and uh I want to see it with an audience
I want to see it with people I've got
tickets
yeah yeah they're on sale did you pay
for them because maybe how much does a
movie cost these days well there's like
those two levels of regular theater and
then they have those lie down ones where
you can get food and take a nap
that's a nice thing to say to Harrison
Ford I bought a napping seat to go see
your movie what the are you doing
I'm not saying during his movie right of
course not I've been waiting for this
for years and those are like 20 dollars
twenty five dollars to lay down and have
a nap
yeah
so you got the special uh well wait a
minute you say you don't know when was
the last time you bought a ticket and
went into a movie theater has it been a
while
uh they're scaring me when you stare at
me like that you said no no you frighten
me to my core no I don't but but I also
don't remember the last uh
you're right you're right I am
I have seen
I have seen movies in on a big screen
yes you know in a in a theater right
right
but there was nobody else in the room
that's how Howard Hughes did it that's
expensive yeah weren't you just at the
Cannes Film Festival you probably saw
some yeah so I saw uh I saw the new
Indian videos
that's right you sat in an audience yeah
I've seen best the last time that guy's
really good yeah yeah well you got in
for free
I would have loved it if they had
stopped you and you had been looking for
your ticket at the can premiere of
Indiana Jones yeah so you were there and
that's that's yeah I know that you've
experienced everything like 10 days ago
yeah yeah everything one can experience
in this business at the highest level
but that still has to be exciting
what part
can film festival you're going up the
big red carpet yeah beautiful wife on
your arm you go inside a whole crowd of
those fancy French people yeah and then
your movie comes up yeah a storied uh
franchise you know I I don't know I just
have to think that there's been some
part of you that would say yes this is
cool
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna wait for you
uh it was uh it was a it was a actually
a pretty
um
uh interesting experience yeah I had I
haven't been there for a while but I had
been there in the past but with other
even Indiana Jones movies anyway yeah it
was it was beautiful uh projection uh um
system great room lots and lots of
people
um but they weren't like a real audience
right I mean they had Tuxedos and
beautiful gowns on and stuff like that
right
uh laughs
so it it you know it didn't I I want to
see it was a yeah ordinary Rebel yeah
you know I got an extra ticket
yeah we can all go together yeah if
you'd like four of us yeah yeah if you'd
like we'll we'll all go together in fact
uh Eduardo you're invited as well oh
yeah
I don't know check your schedule yes no
glare you're in this is the fifth right
yeah of uh
for June yeah that's June 5th yeah June
5th the movie comes out
uh June 30th I believe correct let me
check my incorrect yeah I already know
it's true
okay it says it on the ticket okay
um
oh so we wait here until 25 days only
here for 25 days I like this I'll have
food brought in for you okay we do this
show every
day every day I do now yeah now we do
and you're the only guest every day
and so it's we call it it's a special
promotional month of Harrison Ford
uh and it's you every day for an hour I
promised I wouldn't do this what are you
doing get excited if that's your orgasm
you're a disgusting man I'm just tensing
up an excitement you made it disgusting
that's not what it sounds like
filthy-minded I apologize I apologize
for my partner no it did sound sexual
thank you sorry it might have been well
anyway sorry glad I brought this creep
along
[Music]
thank you
before I do it again you make me blush I
declare
where'd you get that declare where did
you get that southern food
[Laughter]
you had to be here no double yeah this
is oh no you got this is camera stuff
it's awesome yeah you'll see you'll see
this is all going to turn around for you
this podcast